[Music]
you know I uh I came across a good
phrase this weekend a dude was talking
about like some other
video he had made on YouTube and he
referred he was like he referred to it
as dramatically lit okay like
the light the physical lighting okay but
then I'm like I have to use that that's
really funny last night was when you're
dramatically lit
it was a movie last night it was
what was the Bungalow like this weekend
naturally lit yeah actually mood
lighting for sure yeah it was Moody
lighting for sure
yeah but you know
tonight it's going to be dramatically
lit dude I cleaned my house for all of
Saturday no way yeah wow yeah or Friday
props to you man Friday we can't even
get myself to clean my [__] Studio
[__] in the background every one of my
you gotta get that [__] in line I know
because you need to clean your room
what was that Jordan Peterson yeah yeah
right clean your room make your bed
every morning one rule what rules
I cannot get myself to do it and I know
when I do it's gonna be like oh
but I think I'm the thing is I want to
redo that whole room yeah because the
panels look horrible they're all [__]
Brown yeah so I want to like I don't
know
what you're just
I just hate stuff that was it's supposed
it's supposed to be white but it's brown
yeah
welcome back to the most racist podcast
yeah Cody has enough of those in his
life
shut up
[Laughter]
the panels like they're like sun damaged
from my old studio and they're not the
right size they just look bad so I'm
like should I reach should I just build
a crazy studio in there
so then I'm like if I'm gonna do that
I just I have to move this [__] now
right but then you're never gonna build
that you're never gonna build it and
it's always gonna be [__] in the
background and you know my feelings you
know my feels about construction that
you're into it don't do it oh don't do
it yeah yeah but I'm not gonna do
anything like external
even internal you think so yeah if you
built a gym that's like there's like
weight requirements and like structural
things
the only way required is the weight I
need to push yeah no yeah no no you're
right no but it's just like if you
change the flooring if you do stuff to
the walls but if you're just I'm just
gonna put cart like other carpet in oh
yeah you're good and uh and you're good
build other panels
maybe get like a cool like cloud or
whatever I think you should make it all
steel walls
um and you should raise the ceiling 20
feet Reverb chamber yeah so that would
be sick so your house is like all normal
but then your office is clear because
there's a 20-foot lift and they're like
oh what's in there like nothing it's
just up yeah it's just outside but
covered you know be funny is to build
build a room that's like such a Reverb
chamber that it like disorients your
brain right you know when you like lose
hearing and like you don't have any more
balance yeah so you walk in my studio
and you literally collapse because you
can't sense you yeah you get you just
get crazy [__] uh what's it called
Vertigo Vertigo yeah as soon as you walk
in
ow ow
so what what have you been listening to
recently any ear plugs in
yeah
what do you what do you want to make
today that's that's saw seven yeah
instead of like Gore it'll be like clean
you know textured walls and there's
someone sitting there
they're like oh
hell up to their knee
it's a glow see if you can make it out
follow my voice
it's just a 4x4 room
like this is
[Laughter]
dude dude this is dude
there's another room where it's just
softly overpowering yeah so it makes
people feel like they're going crazy
or they're like hello hello hello
[Music]
somebody here
do you have the delay on on the on the
mic right now or what is that what is
that what is that what is that what is
that what's that
I'm like what no nothing nothing I can't
hear anything
happening you cleaned your house cleaned
my house that's six
now I'm turning into a bit of uh
[Music]
dude I'm turning into a [__] uh like
a daily carry guy slightly you know seen
that daily carries like dudes that brag
about their [__] satchels
yeah they take pens and I have a watch
and a gun and oh okay
not completely but daily carry yeah like
as in this is what I carry with me yeah
yeah
everyday carry sorry oh so it's like
okay so it's always like people that are
like I'm always prepared yeah yeah not
not completely I just I did so much
cleaning this is
ready for this
uh my clothes are color coordinated nice
that's sick so uh now I just have now I
have like an American Psycho routine
where everything goes into place yep and
now every day feels like the same no
that is bliss yeah that is actual Bliss
well yeah now my life is gonna seem like
15 minutes
yeah because my brain's gonna go up you
just do a thing every day so that's
that's actual Bliss I'm fast forwarding
to dying yeah yeah
changing my perception of time
that's
depressing yeah so keep it messy man
yeah no it's there's there's actual like
there's like studies where you know if
you like people with
clean homes their relationships are
normally stronger because if you're
you're like your brain releases
serotonin when you're in like a place
that's organized and clean and peaceful
oh yeah Alina gets that so when when two
people are in an organized place
together and they're like releasing
serotonin together they have a stronger
connection well I that explains things
like I don't even have to make love with
Alina anymore why if I just clean the
kitchen she'll just walk in and fall to
her knees oh my God
start oh you yeah I don't want to say
that about your wife yeah yeah yeah I'll
say it she just [__] squirts
everywhere
she just sees our clean kitchen and I
clean I'm just standing in there just
wiping it down I just look up I just
wink and she's
shaking through her [__] pants the
button on her pants
[Laughter]
I'm on a 15 foot ladder
no dude she right when it goes to spray
I just run over with like a like a
bucket I'm just catching it all it
doesn't even touch the paint yeah
I'll say yeah give me that rain water we
can recycle this
is
[Music]
oh damn and on the other hand is a
baseball mitt and I open it up and it
has the button from her jeans
I caught it as soon as it shot off
[Music]
and you're sewing it with the other hand
I am fixing her pants yeah
stop stop
she just explodes
then I laugh and just jump off the
ladder and hang myself